la bataille de l'héritage la raison le
département de la défense s'est dit
ouvert à une discussion sur le fait de
rebaptiser 10 bases militaires un sujet
qui divise outre atlantique
la raison certaines d'entre elles
portent le nombre de généraux favorable
esclavage à l'époque de la guerre de
sécession
mais pour le locataire de la maison
blanche il n'y a pas de débat
il a été suggéré de rebaptiser jusqu'à
10 de nos bases militaires légendaires
comme fort bragg en caroline du nord
fort hood au texas ford benning en
géorgie et cetera ses bases monumentale
et très puissantes sont désormais partie
d'un grand patrimoine américain d'une
histoire de victoires et de liberté les
etats unis d'amérique ont formé déployer
nos héros sur ses terres sacrées et ont
remporté deux guerres mondiales
par conséquent mon administration
n'envisagera même pas de renommer ses
magnifiques et légendaire installations
militaires
notre histoire en tant que plus grande
nation du monde ne sera pas altérée
respecter nos militaires une question
récurrente qui a une nouvelle fois semer
la discorde entre donald trump et la
présidente démocrate de la chambre des
représentants nancy pelosi ou encore le
peuple américain c'est que ces noms
doivent disparaître ces noms sont des
suprémacistes blancs qui ont dit des
choses terribles sur notre pays
plus de cent ans après la seconde guerre
mondiale certains de ces noms ont été
donnés à ses bases
et si vous écoutez qui ils sont et ce
qu'ils ont dit et que vous demandez au
président d'expliquer pourquoi une base
devrait être nommé en leur honneur
il semble être la seule personne qui ne
comprend pas cette dernière a également
appelé au retrait de 11 statut de soldat
et officiels confédérés au capitole un
débat dans un contexte tendu qui agite
l'opinion publique secouée par le récent
décès de georges floyd un afro-américain
mort sous le genou d'un policier le
président des états unis voit sa
popularité diminué dans les sondages son
taux d'approbation a en effet chuté de 5
points lors des trois mois de la crise
sanitaire passant de 47 à 42 % et face à
donald trump dans cette campagne le
candidat démocrate joe biden dénonce le
racisme systémique qui minent les états
unis
ce qui est arrivé à georges floyd
maintenant il ya tant de personnes à
travers le monde qui ont des téléphones
portables des millions cela a changé la
façon dont tout le monde regarde ces
choses regarder des millions de
personnes qui défilent à travers le
monde
donc ce que je veux dire c'est que je
pense que les gens sont en train de
réaliser que ceci est une bataille pour
la halle de l'amérique